so let's go ahead and proceed that was
potty for puppy I'm gonna say firstly
when y equals one on side one minus X
right it's going to intersect with X
plus one once so I'm just going to solve
for these together 1 minus x equals 1
let's have a look at I guess I actually
already know what this is it's x equals
0 ok you can see that the graph
Confederate thank you do you see what I
did by the way I subtracted 1 from both
sides which I can move within their
constant and then I actually don't care
how many X's you've got you can have
half an X 3/4 of X 15 X if it's equal to
0 X is 0 right and my graph kind of
already put me into that fact because
there's the origin right so there's one
solution how am I going to find the
other what am I going to put together
yeah yeah ok so I can substitute this in
to either those equations and I'm going
to get a y-value I cause any coordinates
don't I to get the solution so you can
see off the graph in fact then you can
see here as well you're gonna get a nice
easy like wonderful one all right now to
find the other point intersection to
find the other point of intersection I
used this line first with this one which
one's am I going to combine this time
it's these two right they're going to
intersect to you wherever that happens
to be okay so I'm going to instead of
using 1 minus X I've W that one there
then we'll put intersection I'm going to
do with X minus 1 and the same effects
possible unbranched it up there we go
sorry X minus 1 this has to be a little
bit more careful this side I'll subtract
1/2 X from both sides now what we're
going to do hold on a second I think I
already have if I added if I subtracted
1/2 X from both sides that's gone now
it's come over here I think I can add 1
to both sides right that'll get all the
concerts on one side like so
and now all I have to do is multiply
through multiply through by 2 in the
same way as before I should pop that in
to get a wiring coordinate y equals
let's see x equals 4 y is going to be 3
right
so I have my two points of intersection
and uncut okay now I should point out
even though what I did was I graphed and
then I said okay how do I use that to
solve all I really needed was this bit
and can you see why look at the original
equation look at the original equation
does the original equation have any wise
in it
answer no I introduced those so I could
successfully graph right end of the
two-dimensional thing if the original
question only has to do with X then I
only really need X's as my solutions and
these guys just kind of come along for
the ride they're not necessary they just
help me understand what's going on
all right now just before I finish we've
done this graphically okay it's not the
only way to do it you can do this purely
algebraically but it's quite
time-consuming here is why
think about this um if you want you can
draw this off in the side of the line on
this slide think about how you would
solve this if you did not have a picture
right you'd have to go back and rather
than it's sort of skipping all the
algebra by using a drawing you'd have to
go back to you out to break definitions
right so you have to come back to this
and say okay sometimes this guy is equal
to X minus 1 and sometimes it is equal
to 1 minus X yeah in the same way you'd
have to say sometimes this guy is equal
to 1/2 X plus 1 sometimes it's equal to
the 1/2 X minus 1 and then you have to
try all the combinations how many
combinations on it hmm well it looks to
me like I'm actually going to write
these out the first combination is X
minus 1 is positive 1 and this one
there's the first combination right give
me another one
okay I'll try the other case for this
guy all right give me another one anyway
have a look what am i dealt with so far
yeah I don't both of these versions now
I should try the one man 2 X version and
there's one last case which is okay now
there are four cases except I want you
to look really carefully that case one
and case before can you look at us for a
second what do you notice about them
do you notice if you wanted to there's
no really reason to but you can you can
go straight from case one to case for
solving case one solves case for do you
see why what is it that they share in
common or maybe how do I get from case
one to case for what has to be done to
both sides there yeah
and that shouldn't surprise us because
this left-hand side is the negative
version of this and this Nate moves left
and right hand side is the negative
version of that right
so they're actually parallel so
therefore you don't have to worry about
this case there's another case you don't
have to worry about can you see which
one it is
this time maybe you can actually use
this to your advantage
can you see which case can be ignored I
think we can ignore case two we are at a
bit of an advantage because we've
already solved this question case one is
this one see that that's I'm literally a
written it just there case three is the
first one I started with okay now why
can I ignore case - well because I can
see from the graph okay except when you
haven't drawn a graph you don't know it
that yet so watch what happens this is
actually important follow with me what
happens if we go ahead and solve this
reader case - you're supposed to ignore
okay what should I do to both sides how
do I miss office I can add one to both
sides so that's gonna get rid of those
two guys there okay and then what do you
get left with
X what do you get hold on a second look
carefully
oh okay you've just done you haven't
done anything from day yes now am I did
we go I guess an eye can add 1/2 X to
both sides that gives me 3 1 2 x equals
0 so wait a second what's happened oh my
god I've already done with this haven't
I I already found the solution for this
okay so it's kind of like what was the
point
there was no there's no in their game
from doing that having done these two I
know I get the two solutions that I want
okay there's one other thing that can
happen sometimes you don't get a
solution you already have occasionally
you'll get a solution like say I don't
know as an example you might get
something like this okay now could
anyone say have a look at the graph why
might that be a problem okay now hold on
a second I'll take this idea but I'm
going to push on it a little bit it's
true we're looking at an absolute value
problem so we shouldn't have any
negative things down here okay however X
I'm sorry there you want maybe even
things down here
that's why I'd write pretty cool stuff
so why I can't be negative X can't be
negative right like I actually can in
theory get values that are on the left
hand side not on the right that's what x
equals negative 1 means so it's true
that I can't have negatives but not that
kind of thing there's another problem
with this solution
hmm can you come back to this data
negative 1/2 X minus 1
where does he exists because he doesn't
always exist right you only exists
sometimes where have i drawn this go
back to my graph and Tommy in what
domain have i drawn it you know Tony
what's this son
what's this point young it's when X is
negative but it's not just X is negative
it's more than just negative this value
over here is negative 2 you can go ahead
and check it actually go ahead and graph
it and you'll see ok if that's negative
2 the only place where this exists is
where X is less than negative 2 it's on
this side do you agree but the solution
I found isn't in that zone over there
right so you're like oh it's ok I found
this solution baqia it's meant to be
here except he doesn't exist over there
I haven't drawn here right the absolute
value of 1/2 X plus 1 doesn't equal that
when x equals negative 1 it only equals
that when X is less than negative 2 ok
now that's actually quite hard to see if
all you've got is just algebra right
which is why the picture which is why
the drawing is so instructive and why
even when you don't get asked to do it I
recommend you're just a really rough one
on your own page just the tiny one so
you can see which branches are going to
intersect you don't have to do this work
you can see it's going to be this one
and this one and you know which one to
ignore okay